well while some members of the left are
doubling down on their woke ideologies
others see the virginia race as a
reckoning for the party
moving around it's just stupid wokeness
all right don't just look at virginia
and new jersey look at long island look
at buffalo look at minneapolis even look
at seattle washington i mean just defund
the police lunacy just take abraham
lincoln's name off of schools i mean
that
people see that
and it it it it's it's just really uh
have a suppressive effect all across the
country the democrats some of these
people that need to go to a woke detox
center or something
well joining me now is james most nerdly
he's at golden he is the author of the
upcoming book rush on the radio welcome
and what's your reaction does he have a
point there
james carville does i hate to say it but
james carville yes has a point wokeness
is actually putting democrats to sleep
there are electoral chances anyway
across the country because what you have
is a radicalism that can't be hidden
from the american people anymore and you
have today just today
aoc
went on the launch pad that the reason
they lost the election was because they
were too moderate and so she wants more
to which i say
by all means please go even further to
the left and lose more elections and
let's see what happens in 2022
so what is the lesson officially for not
just for democrats but for republicans
from last night
well the lessons for republicans well
they would be taking the wrong lesson
away by the way as i've heard some of
the pundits say
that this is proof that they should
distance from trump
that was the trump base that came out
and be very clear about that
so the second lesson that they should
take
is to
be
optimistic
a happy warrior if you look at what
happened in virginia especially you just
had the lieutenant governor on very
optimistic
very positive thinking the governor is
the same way he talked about the promise
that virginia had for their children he
talked about educating making virginia a
place where people wanted to live he
never gave in to the negativism coming
from the intellectually lazy left who
can only engage in name calling what he
did was offer an optimistic viewpoint
for the people of virginia and it
resonated he also talked about the
concerns of parents
and these are real concerns and that
resonated what did obama do when he came
to town what did joe biden do they
demonized parents it didn't work stay
optimistic and stay on course and you
will win elections